hey gq this is lakeith stanfield and
today i'm going undercover
on the internet
[Music]
you may not believe it but
it's actually me first up youtube
[Music]
the keith stanford goes sneaker shopping
with complex
yeah it was fun you know the funny thing
is i'm not really
like a sneaker head i'm not really into
that kind of stuff in that way
so i just looked at it as an opportunity
to have fun so no one is going to talk
about how he pulled out a credit card
from a shoe he wasn't wearing
where did the shoe come i had it on when
i arrived
you do not walk the streets of new york
with no shoes that's the damn show
key stanford breaks down his fashion
looks from selma to atlanta
how does one view numbers with intention
same way you view anything else with
intention you just view it with intent
for instance i can imbue my intention
into a work of
literature try and uh hope to derive
something useful out of it basically
just putting your energy towards
something is
really all it means replied
what people think about choosing their
mind not yours
man what people think about you is in
their mind not yours so
i don't really care that much yeah
there's a bunch of ideas people have
about you all day but you know they kind
of
got to live with that more than you do
as you grow you start to see that it
doesn't really
have as much an impact on things and how
you feel
as you thought when you're younger
someone might judge you and say
something about you when you're younger
and it throws you into a
frenzy for the rest of the day week year
but as you get older you start to
realize those things don't
[ __ ] matter
[Music]
keith wraps i love them even more now
why thank you
i do i'm working on my first album right
now
which is pretty exciting and i kind of
just want to get it out because it's a
lot of personal stuff too but
yeah twitter
i know everyone wants to see him as a
joker but what about the key stanford
that's the riddler
i like this person i like how this
person thinks a lot
have y'all ever seen keith stanfield and
terence frost in the same room
okay first time i heard terrence ross i
didn't know who he was but now i kind of
get where you going with it you know i
don't know if i feel like we look alike
like that but
i feel like you don't reply watching the
quincy jones talk on netflix and i can't
stop thinking
is it me or should the key stanford play
young quincy in the bio
well that would be quite an honor to do
some
consulting with my spirits to see if
that's something that's in the cards for
me
he's cool though quincy's awesome so
you're telling me that was a key stamp
for the snoop and shout out to compton
that's what i'm telling you it was me
bro i didn't really get very much prep
time at all they were really looking
hard for a snoop and
just showed up and gave it my best um
that i could do i met stoop
at the premiere i sort of swam through
a bunch of wheat smoking and finally
found him
yeah he said good job nephew so i got an
uncle
oh wow i'm actually drawing on the thing
that's crazy put a little happy face
right next to it why does every
character the key stanford play have a
girl that can't get over him
i don't even know how this this trend
has happened
i love love and showing the various
stages of it
and breakup is just one part of it you
know
break up to make up love is kind of
universal for all of us
and it involves connections and pain and
loss and gain
and happiness and sex and all those cool
things
boom which celebrity are you attracted
to but you can't explain why
i'll start with keith stanford thanks
for that backhanded ass compliment
no i mean i can't explain it either
before i'm attracted to me
i'm not attracted to me posted out of
nowhere i've just become obsessed with
the idea
of a bumbling detective movie starring
keith stanfield
and adam sandler can i will this into
existence
please do i just want to work with adam
again he's amazing
yeah please do that pray for me of
course i grew up on house and
man you know i've always been a fan he's
always been
a great performer very funny very smart
he's like one of those people you think
are your friends in your mind as you're
growing up and then you know
god willing become friends with them in
real life which i've had the opportunity
to do which is quite amazing
what summer blockbuster are you willing
to risk you and your family's health
over
for me it's gotta be a superhero movie
or something starting with kate stanley
that's sweet but don't risk your health
stay home wear a mask it's quite nice
though
instagram
[Music]
what class were you attending yeah this
is when we were in
rehearsals for changers and dance
stories by jones
which we performed in new york a little
over a week and it was very very awesome
and cool and a great learning experience
with mia and
the team was just very talented and i
realized how
athletic i need to be how much i need to
engage in
physical activity those last couple days
were a bit grueling there but it was
beautiful and
i love the experience oh instagram i
could zoom
right here from the screen that's crazy
wait nobody's going to ask him where he
got the wig from because ready to get
the wig from bro
it's beautiful there's this little place
called iguana in studio city
that's where i got most of my wigs from
in the early days i believe around the
time i'm sorry to bother you
i bought a bunch of tickets and then hid
them in wigs and hit them around in
theaters
it's not a fun easter egg type thing
people did find tickets
um either they found them or they blew
away in the wind but they weren't there
when i went back so
something happened posted
where can i buy this jacket coach
the coach was very kind and give to me
that jacket it's a very beautiful one
and quite comfy on the inside that
little fur
thing works quite well to insulate the
body atlanta star like keith stanfield
and boondock's co-creator
john thomas are teaming up for netflix
original anime yoshi what's your
favorite anime
oh man i hate this question because i
always feel like i'm not learning
enough inanimate but right now i'm basic
[ __ ] dragon ball z
and uh i like death note a lot too send
me anime i need to
learn all the ways but i'm
really excited about this project it'll
be another one in the canon hopefully
that people enjoy wikipedia
keith stanfield was born in san
bernardino california on august 12
1991 and grew up in riverside in
victimhood
facts this is all true yeah it was a
pretty
small world um i lived in small
apartments
and stuff and so i moved to victorville
we were able to get a larger house
because
it's cheaper um but yeah it was a
pretty close-knit type situation with me
in the family and then
you always envision l.a as like the big
city or something i was going to go
there and try and
make my dreams come true and i got here
and it was a city
but it wasn't quite everything i'd
imagined
there would be a long sort of check
upward
and falling and getting back up to try
and
you know secure my dream mckee
stanford's first role
was in the short film short term 12
2009. yeah that was my first
official time on set i've been shooting
myself before
and just like cameras laying around the
house but that was the first time that i
really um had stepped foot on a
real set it was it was awesome a year
later he appeared in the short film give
me grace before giving up akron for
several years
i don't know where this rumor came from
that i gave up um
maybe it was a miscold or something by
somebody but i never gave up i just
didn't have means to continue to pursue
so i had to find ways to survive for a
little while
um and while i was still actively
pursuing it
yeah i was working at atnt and i got
fired but i had signed up
i moved to sacramento and signed up on a
film board out there so the day i got
fired
i checked the film board that i signed
up to and saw that i had some messages
from the director
and it was um and it was destined
and he was telling me about short-term
12 to feature version
so i guess the the the whole moral of
the story is even when you're doing
other things
actively still be seeking out what
you're doing because you never know
where the next opportunity may come
personal life stanfield was a member of
a band named moores
yeah i created this little thing called
morris with my friend rishi who's um
a very talented musician he has a
podcast now called song exploder
we got along very well and we're able to
just stream songs together nicely
i was mainly just a vocalist you know
i'd like to convince myself
that i'm instrumental as well but just
because you placed a couple sounds
on the board doesn't mean you're really
an instrument with uh yeah i was
primarily a
rapper now i sort of operate under la
keith moore's will always be in my heart
quora
is the key stanfield overrated i don't
know
you tell me i don't even know how i'm
rated
and probably underrated what makes the
key standpoint such an
interesting actor to watch perhaps i
listen to
my co-workers like when you're acting i
think the important thing is kind of
listening
a lot of people overlook a little bit
it's hard to focus when you're acting a
lot of time and scenes and so
one good way to focus is just to listen
and really listen to what the person's
saying you know like really be
engaged and it gives you a point to
focus and some where to go
you know otherwise you're kind of just
like
with his head cut off just kind of just
doing whatever you think the camera will
want to see
which is also fun but you know i prefer
to listen more
next why does the key stand to look so
sad
i guess i just wear it on my face don't
no you know
i guess i just got resting depressed
face i'm not really that sad i mean most
times you know
should lekit stanfield take super one
should the key stanford play joker in
the dc eu that's up to you guys
make your voices heard go out and vote
but after you vote vote for me is joker
in the dceu imdb
trivia got his first agent by doing a
circus game
yeah i just jumped up in the chair and
started doing some surfer stuff you know
whatever i thought it was a surfer which
clearly surfers don't do what i did
but i guess it just tickled the agent
enough to
the ross is interested in me so he
signed me i was very surprised
and very happy and i would start going
on
um commercial auditions those are the
first auditions i went on
and i never booked anything but i
learned how to
like deal with auditions so that was a
good thing
reddit
i like ready ryan cooper produces jesus
was my homeboy starring daniel color
lucky stanfield and ashley
sanders is this movie an adaptation of
rapping for jesus
not sure what that is so no
it's about fred hampton the life of fred
anthony was a brilliant
beautiful human being and stood up for
the truth
and was murdered by people who couldn't
handle the truth i'm excited about this
one
early in especially in these times it'd
be nice to
communicate with people in this way
identification can anyone help me
identify the watch worn by the cute
stamp pillow knives
i've searched and can't find any
information my husband loves it
i wish i could i don't know it was big
though i'm
quite skinny so it's hard to keep it
from sliding up my
arm i think i had to put like some
little
styrofoam in there or something to keep
it right but yeah it's nice
if you thick gq thank you
so much thank you everyone for watching
um
it was that was pretty [ __ ] fun i'm
signing out off of the internet
for the rest of eternity i'm gonna keep
[Music]
this